FEMALE SPEAKER: --examine
the ancient climate
and migration
patterns in Africa.
Currently, Professor Ampim
is a tenured professor
of history at
Contra Costa college
in San Pablo, California
in the east bay.
And he also teaches in African
American Studies department
at Merritt college in Oakland.
He also created a seven step
primary research methodology
home study course at
advancing the research.
His latest work is the formation
of the Save Nubia Project,
Which aims to help preserve
the archaeological sites
of ancient Kush and Nubia in
the Sudan, which are threatened
by the construction of dams.
Anything else that I
was remiss in saying,
Professor Ampim, I'm
sure, will let you know.
Without further ado, please
welcome Professor Ampim.
MANU AMPIM: How's everybody?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MANU AMPIM: OK.
Good to see you all.
Everybody was nice and quiet
and patient and whispering
and-- or on their
laptops I like--
that's what I tell my students.
When you come in,
you should be focused
on something
constructive rather than
talking about the
news of the day.
Anyway, good to see all.
I have the pleasure of
really sharing with you
the fruits of my primary
research over the last quarter
century.
I want to thank
Umani for her effort
to help bring everyone
together and Duane really
informing people about
African civilization
because most times people only
focused on this topic when?
Generally, when?
What time of year?
AUDIENCE: Ferbruary.
MANU AMPIM: In February.
What I say, as a historian,
is that we really
should focus on
it 366 days a year
because it is that
much information that
has to be shared.
So I'm going to just
focus on math and science
as some of the
African contributions
because they don't get
discussed very often.
And I teach at
Contra Costa college.
And we have people in
the scientific areas,
and they more often
than not-- not
always-- more often than
not, they overlook Africa.
They look at the
history of engineering,
on math or science.
And I just find it
strange because I've
gone to so many countries
around the world
to do firsthand research.
I've gone to institutions,
libraries, and museums
throughout the US,
Canada, Europe,
and I'll find the
complete opposite
of what's taught
in the classroom.
That Africans have made
a tremendous contribution
to technology and
many other fields.
That's really what I'm
going to focus on today.
And our Save Nubia
Project-- I have a brochure
I'll pass around, but
this is the fruits
of some of my research in Sudan,
in Egypt, and Ethiopia where
you have classical African
civilizations now, maybe
ancient Kush and Nubia,
that are under threat.
But since we don't
have a lot of time,
I'll just will move forward.
Anybody know who this-- why
this individual is important,
Dr. Carter G. Woodson?
What is his role?
What is his contribution?
Why would I want to
dedicate this presentation
to Dr. Woodson.
OK, let me help you out.
He's a founder of
what we now call
African Heritage Month,
or Black History month.
He found, what was then called
Negro History Week, in 1926
because he said that the
contributions by people
of African descent really is a
part of US and world history,
yet these are the missing pages.
And Dr. Woodson
though, back in 1926,
that it would mean a lot if
we included these pages back
into the historical text.
And he's one of the greatest
historians of our time.
He's done quite a lot.
I mean he's wrote more than
a dozen books, Dr. Woodson.
His organization,
The Association
for the Study of African
American Life and History,
founded in 1915, is
still the leading
African American historical
organization in the country.
Every year, they have
an annual convention.
And the Journal of Negro
History has been updated.
Now, it's the Journal of
African American history.
It's the leading
journal in the country.
So we know Woodson quite a lot.
And he founded the occasion
more than 88 years ago.
And there was a
stamp in his honor.
And one of his classic books,
he's wrote more than a dozen,
on the miseducation
of Negroes and really
focuses on the
American education
system that really leaves
out students of color,
in particular people
of African descent,
from their own
contributions to the world.
And so he's one of the great
historians of our time.
So now, you all know
the great Dr. Woodson.
And moving forward--
well, I won't
to focus on northeast
Africa and contributions
mainly from ancient Egypt.
And as you can see,
this is a map of Africa.
And I was there last
year, and I can assure you
that Egypt did not
detach itself from Africa
and float off to
the Middle East.
I double checked.
I triple checked.
And when I was in Egypt,
I was on African soil.
So it's still part of
the African continent,
even today, even thought it's
not really taught that way.
So this is the area here.
So I've done research in
different parts of the world,
but today, I'll focus
mainly on Egypt.
But a lot of my work
on classical Africa
has been in Northeast
African corridor.
And so the three classical
African civilizations
are Kush, Nubia, and Kemet.
People know Kemet as Egypt.
But this is the Greek word.
And there's no reason really to
use Greek words because we know
the original word from
the hieroglyphic text.
So we use the word classical
because it's more important
if you use that
that than ancient.
We here about classical
music, classical--
what-- classical theater,
classical dance, classical art.
So what does classical mean?
Why would I put emphasis
on classical and not simply
ancient.
Even though ancient
civilization-- African
civilization would be
technically correct,
but what about classical?
What does the term
actually mean?
And we do here.
We use it.
We read about it.
Anybody?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Maybe it
stood the test of time.
It st--
AUDIENCE: It stood
the test of time.
MANU AMPIM: Stood
You're correct.
I like that.
Anybody else?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: It's still relevant.
MANU AMPIM: Still relevant.
Yes, absolutely.
You both are correct.
So when you say
classical, we mean
anything that's the standard,
the model, the guide,
the highest rank,
the highest class.
As you've said, you're correct.
Anything that has permanent
and lasting values.
That's what's
meant by classical.
That's why we call
these classical African
civilizations.
And the oldest of them is Kush.
This a map of Kush.
Kush is the area of
northeast Africa,
but not only northeast
Africa, but across the Red
Sea into Saudi Arabia and Yemen.
All of this was a part of
the ancient Kushite empire.
You can see it
here in the inset.
That's the area.
That's the oldest of
the civilizations.
And Kush was based
in modern day Sudan.
That's why I spend a
lot of time in the area.
This is the area where
there's massive pyramids
and elaborate temples and
great writing and science.
And so most people are
not aware that there's
twice as many pyramids in
Sudan as there is in Egypt.
Civilization spread from south
to north, not the other way
around.
And so that's why I've done
extensive, firsthand research
in order to document this.
This is one statue
made out of granite.
One of the powerful
Kushite kings.
Can you imagine standing
under a 30 foot statue
made by one of the most
powerful rulers of the time.
So this is why I
spend so much time
because the public,
in general, is not
too familiar with these
powerful Kushite rulers.
This is a 2,800 year
old statue here.
And then, also,
some of you possibly
could have seen this image here.
Sometimes, people have it
on posters or handbags.
If you go to the African
flea market in Berkeley,
I've seen this
sometimes on t-shirts.
But these are Kushite princes.
And this is a 3,5000 year
old mural or drawing.
And we know that they
are high stature,
notice the crowns on their head.
Notice the almond-shaped eyes.
Notice the skin variation.
Here it says in the
glyphs, it says Kush
so we know where they're from.
Notice the nice
jewelry, the sandals
who you have the
attendant assisting.
And here you have an assistant
with his arms outstretched.
He has something
draped over this arm.
What do you think this might
be that's draped over his arm
here?
OK.
It's an animal.
Yes, it's a leopard skin outfit
worn by priests and kings
to what purpose?
I'm glad you asked.
For the purpose of
rituals and ceremonies.
And then, the same
assistant is carrying--
you see three rings,
here another three.
And so three
indicates plurality.
When something is pleural or
in abundance, you see three.
So it means there's a
lot of whatever this is.
Anybody have an idea
what this would be?
What is the assistant carrying?
AUDIENCE: A whole
lot of scrolls?
MANU AMPIM: OK.
Good try.
Not exactly.
Something a little more hard.
AUDIENCE: Gold.
MANU AMPIM: Gold.
And there's currently,
right now in 2014,
there's actually a
gold rush in Sudan now.
Literally, there's
gold everywhere.
In fact, the word Nubia-- the
root, nu or nub, it means gold.
So Nubia, more likely than
not, means the land of gold.
And now when you go
to Sudan, there's
people panning for gold
everywhere literally.
So anyway, if we had time,
we would talk about that.
But really today, I want to
really talk about the third
of these classical
African civilizations,
which is actually listed
on the glyphs here.
So let me point out what
glyphs I'm referring to.
And it's these glyphs here.
And this spelled Kemet, or
so called ancient Egypt.
So this is what do you think?
It's an owl.
Yes, it represents the em sound.
And this is a burnt
piece of charcoal.
This is a half a loaf of bread.
This is a crossroad.
This is where-- it's the
locale where people lived.
This the actual name.
There's no such name as Egypt
until the Greeks come along
much later.
So many of the
African countries,
these are not original
African names.
So I just wanted
to point that out.
And all right, let's
focus on writing
before we deal with more
of the hard sciences here.
African contributions in the
field of writing most of us--
Most of us are not
always necessarily
familiar with the source of
what we have in front of us
on a regular basis, paper.
So this is actual papyrus plant.
It grows in marshes.
So they would take
the papyrus plant.
And then, they would
cut it into strips.
eventually make paper.
So from papyrus, we
get the word paper.
And this is an
important contribution.
This is some of the
writing, the text here.
You always read the
text from top to bottom.
This is text inside a pyramid,
so people call it pyramid text.
And even without ever
studying the language,
I bet that most of you can
figure out some of these images
without ever having taken any
class or seminar or training.
So for example, this
here is the shenu,
or what people now
call a cartouche.
It's the ring of eternity.
It's the name of the King
you see inside of here.
But what is this symbol here?
You see this is not
the best resolution,
but-- it's kind
of pixelated here,
but I guess you can
see-- you see the ears?
OK, this is a rabbit.
This is a ripple of water.
Anyway, this is the King's name.
What about this?
There's a bird, yes.
An owl, yes.
This is a chick.
You see this here?
It's outstretched arms.
So if I said to you where is
the place of Memphis in Egypt,
and you say I don't know.
This means not to
know something.
But you can make these out.
So we would just
have to give you
training on what
the sound value is,
but you can actually make
up some of the images
without taking a class.
But anyway, so I wanted
to show you some of these.
And this is scribal
equipment that-- there
is a scribe's palate.
And I'm showing this
to you because I'm
going to show you
the first writer
in the history of the world.
And these are
actual scribes here
with their writing
utensil, their board.
This is a scribes equipment.
And so what they have in their
hands is this pallet here.
And so you see this
everywhere in Egypt, or Kemet.
And here's another palate
in different colors.
The two main colors were
always black and red.
This man here is a scribe.
He's a writer.
Does anybody see any
indication of him
being a writer or scribe?
There is actually three things
that indicates his profession.
AUDIENCE: He's
writing in his book.
MANU AMPIM: OK,
great observation.
Who said that?
Very good.
This is actually a scroll.
You see it's rolled up here.
So he's using his
kilt, not a dress.
But he's using his kilt.
He's pulling it tight,
his kilt, in order
to use that as a
writing service.
You know like when we write,
we usually want something hard.
And then, in his hand,
what's broken off
is the reed in that he
would have been writing.
This is the scroll.
Here is another
indication of the fact
that he is in fact a scribe.
This is a scribe's palatte.
This would have
been black and red.
So we know his profession
by the symbols,
but also the glyphs tell
us his profession as well.
And here you see black and red.
This is actual paintings.
This is a stone surface.
But if you notice
that on the left
is darker than on the right.
Do you see that?
Any idea why it would
be two different colors?
You might say maybe one
was exposed to the sun.
No, not that one.
But notice that this one here
still has the horizontal lines.
So this is an unfinished piece.
It's not finished.
It is a trial
piece, but it still
is interestingly is
two different colors.
Here's why.
This is the image that
was drawn by the master.
And to the right is what the
students were practicing on.
Notice that they were
practicing arm and the hand.
Notice this one here almost
looks like the thumb is broke.
The student did
the best he could
or she could but-- So they were
practicing an arm and a hand.
You see here they
are practicing.
This is the quail chick.
And so why is this lighter?
Because when students practice,
sometimes, they have to erase.
So that's what
they're doing here.
They're practicing and erasing.
But the master is not erasing.
And this is a
science by the way.
This is science.
You have a King
sitting on his throne.
We know that because
of the sceptor here
in his hand and the
mace, the royal beard,
his name is [INAUDIBLE].
But not only that,
but what we have here
is the science as it is
seen by the modern viewer.
So that's from
the soldier's feet
to the hairline, when they're
seated, it's always 14.
Not sometimes, not most
the times, but always.
They could make a small trial
piece into a colossal statue.
And then, it's built
to absolute perfection.
So if you count, we have
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 and then
14 at the hairline.
If this was a standing
figure, it would be 18.
There's no variation
when this is
done by royal artists who
are trained by the state.
So we all know rules,
regulations, procedures.
They believe that this
is divine art given
to them by the
creator, so there's
no such thing as
artistic license.
You must follow the rules.
Anyway, so let me
move forward and show
you the writer of
the very first book
in the history of the world.
I didn't say one of.
The author of the
very first book.
This is Ptah Hotep and he was
a prime minister, high priest.
And by the way, no one
could hold high office
like a prime minister, which is
similar to our vice president,
second in line to only the
pharoah, unless the person was
a priest or priestess.
So they had to be a
spiritual practitioner first.
He's the author of the
world's first book.
This is an image of Ptah Hotep.
Here he is.
This is about 2,400 BCE,
or before the common era.
And this is Ptah Hotep
inside of his tomb.
And this is his tomb here.
Here's a close up of his tomb.
So 2,400 BC.
That's the same as
2,400 years ago.
And Ptah Hotep
wrote the first book
in the history of humanity.
This is it.
It's part of the text,
so this is cursive.
So when they wanted to write
fast, like we write in cursive.
So they didn't always
write in glyphs.
They wrote in glyphs if it
was something on temple walls.
So what does this contain?
37 lessons on ethical
or moral conduct.
So the first book ever written
in the history of humanity
had nothing to do with
fighting, warfare, or conflict.
It was quite the
opposite, presenting
moral and ethical conduct
and social wisdom on how
to avoid conflict, how
to avoid social problems,
how to show respect for elders.
So now we have two main colors.
We have black and red.
Why do you think that you
see intermittent red here?
Why would the author, Ptah Hotep
use red at different places
in his text.
And by the way, this is a text
used in the school system.
We know that because
there's different versions
of this text found
throughout Egypt.
So clearly this is what
young boys and girls
would have learned.
Yeah, girls wrote as well,
and they were taught.
Red represents a
different lesson.
So whenever you see
red text, that's
either if it's a medical
document, it's a new case.
If it's a mathematical
document, it's a new problem.
But, in this case,
it's moral lessons
taught so it's a new chapter.
And that's what we have here.
So this is the first
book ever written.
These are the
instructions of Ptah Hotep
if we typed them out.
And it says, the wisdom
or the maximum Ptah Hotep.
And it says his title as a
so-called prime minister.
But anyway, this
is some of the text
of Ptah Hotep in
the second stanza.
He's talking about leadership
and that all leaders must
have character.
Character means to build.
Today, in our
country, a person can
be almost an outlaw,
a former outlaw
and be a leader
later on, not so much
the case in classical Africa.
One must first have
character and everything
was based on Maat, truth,
justice, and righteousness.
Just everything
was bound by Maat.
So if we had more time,
I would focus on it more.
But I just want to show you
some of what he talked about.
Leadership, known as
Ptah Hotep-- he says,
do great things which will
be remembered long after you.
So it's your reputation that
Ptah Hotep is discussing.
And not only that,
but he also mentions,
as all of the wisdom
texts discusses,
that is hearing well.
He owned the most commonly
used verb in classical Africa
is the word or the
verb [? sejum ?].
[? Sejum ?] means to
hear or to listen.
So it's always wisdom text
regarding hearing well.
And this is what he says.
"If a son and daughter
accept the righteous teaching
of their parents, none of
their plans will go wrong.
Teach your children, then,
to be those that hear well,
and they will be valued by
those of weight and substance
and their speech
will be informed
by what they have heard.
Respected are those
who listen well."
So think about it.
We have two ears, two eyes.
But how many mouths?
Just one.
So Ptah Hotep reminds us of
how we should communicate.
Some people don't listen
as well as they should.
That's why I put great
emphasis on listening.
So that's why you have this as
the most commonly used verb.
Anyway, so that's writing.
But I really want to
focus more on math here
and the other sciences
since we are at Google
and you all deal with
a lot of technology.
Well, here is the eye
of Heru, or Horus.
And by the way, if you
see words like Horus--
Some you might know
Isis, these names.
If it ends in is, us,
os, more likely than not,
it is taken on as Grecian form.
The original words would
have ended in other letters,
but os, us, is, is
usually the Grecian form.
So the Greeks couldn't
really pronounce the word,
so they did the best they could.
So you have the
all-seeing eye of Heru
in different capacities.
Here is a nice
beautiful bracelet.
And this is the eye.
They call it the Uoajat
Eye, or the Sound Eye.
It has to do with medicine
but also mathematics.
So every aspect of
the eye, the eyelash,
every aspect of the eye
represents a fraction.
And if you added up these
fractions, it would be 63, 64.
So we believe that this
symbol that you see everywhere
in Kemet is also the RX symbol
that's used today in pharmacy.
And there's many
things that we can
point to to go back to
this area because it's also
a medical symbol as well.
It's called the Sound Eye
because, in the mythology,
Heru loses his eye
and, through magic,
Djehuti restores
the eye of Heru.
And so it's also
called the Sound Eye.
And so anyway, but we believe
this RX symbol goes back
to that.
But anyway, here's
the Eye of Heru.
This is mathematics.
This is some of the writing.
You can actually
learn the writing.
One stroke represents one.
Or, you have an arch
here representing 10.
So you can actually, if
you see these images,
you actually can
figure out the writing.
But nevertheless, this is
a very elaborate system
of writing and numbers
that could be learned.
But they were very
sophisticated.
So here is the oldest
mathematical text.
This text is not
totally complete,
but it's the oldest
mathematical writings
in the history of the world that
we have on papyrus, or paper.
It's called the Moscow
Mathematical Papyrus.
It has nothing to do with
Moscow other than the fact
that that's where
it was taken to.
So that's how
history is distorted
when people name documents
based on who found it
or where it happens to be now.
There's no reason to call
this the Moscow Mathematical
Papyrus.
Anyways, it's 3,800
year old papyrus.
Here's some of the writings.
And this is a focus
on calculating
the volume of a cone or pyramid.
So a lot of those
sophisticated algorithms,
they have an origin.
They don't have an
origin in Greece.
We have it in writing that's
pinned by ancient scribes.
So the Moscow document
is very important,
but let me show you one that's
even more popular or famous
or perhaps even more
important as a much more
complete mathematical document.
In this one here, this is
a copy of a book that's
called The Rhind
Mathematical Papyrus,
an ancient Egyptian text.
The only issue here is that
Alexander Rhind purchased
the document more than 3,000
years after it was written.
So why is it now
named after him.
We actually know the name of
the African scribe, Ahmose,
who wrote the document.
In fact, Ahmose
made it very clear
that he did not write these
mathematical equations
and create them.
He was simply copying them
for a much older document.
Because at 1,600
before the common era,
3,600 years ago, there
was no copy machines,
no fax machines, no scanners.
So what did the scribes do?
They copied by hand.
And all Ahmose is
simply saying is
that he followed the
instructions of the pharaoh
to copy the document,
the much older document
by hand into the new document.
And that's why we have his name.
He's not claiming
to know or to be
the one who invented
the knowledge.
So here we have with
this document 87
advanced mathematical problems
without one single error.
Trigonometry, calculus,
geometry, arithmetic,
not one single error, and
this is important to know.
So we don't typically
learn these things.
We have to come to a seminar
like this to see the document.
Anybody know where this
document is by the way?
So it's not just
general information.
OK.
Anybody name a famous or
popular museum in England.
AUDIENCE: The Brooklyn Museum.
MANU AMPIM: Which one?
MANU AMPIM: OK, the Brooklyn
museum is a good try.
Yes, you said the--
the British Museum.
I'm going to say we're going
to give you half credit
cause you said b for Brooklyn.
But it's actually
British Museum.
But good try because
the Brooklyn Museum,
they do have a lot of material.
So the British Museum, you're
going to the British Museum.
OK, so the second
part of the test.
What city is it
in, British Museum?
AUDIENCE: London.
MANU AMPIM: OK, it's in London.
All right.
So you go to London, British
Museum, second floor,
you'll see the Rhind
Mathematical Papyrus.
So all right.
So 87 advanced
mathematical problems.
This is how it starts off.
Notice it's a red.
This is the beginning
of the text.
And then, you have black.
And the problem
is the word Rhind.
So I think it's a good
idea to get rid of the name
because it's totally inaccurate.
And why don't we call it
what it should be called.
And what do you
think we should call
it to make it more accurate?
AUDIENCE: Ahmose.
MANU AMPIM: Why not.
Give Ahmose credit
for what he did.
He copied it from
an older document.
And if we take a look at the
beginning of the papyrus here,
this is actually what it says.
It's not simply math, but it's
much more deeper than that.
It says as it starts off here.
It's almost like a title of it.
It says accurate
method of counting
for grasping the
meaning of things
and knowing everything that
is, all mysteries and secrets.
That's a bad document.
So this is how it starts
off, so very powerful.
All right, so take
a look at this.
So we know that, in
California, every 10th grader
has to learn the so-called
Pythagorean theorem, which
is a squared plus b
squared equals c squared.
This is how it's
always presented.
It is presented in math
classes, social studies,
but we don't always go deeper.
I do, but most people don't.
So what do we know
about the Pythagoras.
Remember the date I gave
you for the document?
We'll remind you in a minute.
But Pythagoras lived about
500 before the common era.
So there's already
an issue here.
And the issue about Pythagoras
is that there's no teachers.
There's no teachers of geometry
that Pythagoras could've
benefited from to learned from.
There's no schools of geometry.
There's no books of
geometry in Greece, not one.
And so where did
he get this from?
I'll give you the sources, so
if you want to go check it out,
we'll give you the sources.
We know from several
Greek writers themselves
that Pythagoras
left Greece and went
to Egypt, which is in Africa,
and studied for 22 years
under who?
A priest.
And that's where he
learned geometry.
Then, he goes back to
Greece teaching a subject
that he didn't
know when he left.
And so documentation
beats conversation,
so let's give you
the documentation.
Because we can talk about
these things, but let's
give you some of the evidence.
Here is Ahmose Papyrus.
So this was written 1600.
That's more than 1,000 years
before Pythagoras' mother even
knew him.
So how in the wold did
the man create something
that pre-existed 1,000
years before he's around?
And take a look 87 lessons.
And notice, this
is a squared plus
b squared-- we're just
looking at a right
here on the actual document.
Told you where it was.
You go to the British
Museum, second floor.
It's there.
Or, you could purchase the book.
And you can get it
there if you don't
get a chance to go to London.
So this so-called Pythagorean
theorem has no basis in fact,
so let's get rid of it.
What should we call it.
Why not call it
what it should be
called it's the Ahmose theorem.
Right?
This is logical.
We're in a place
where logic reigns.
Doesn't it reign
and rule at Google?
This is my assumption
as a guess.
Ya'll are employees so-- it
is how-- don't you think?
AUDIENCE: Ahmose copied
it from as well though.
MANU AMPIM: Yeah, but he
copied it from his own people,
so at least call it the Ahmose
slash ancient Egyptian theorem,
at least that.
But Ahmose would not have
claimed ownership of it
because Africans
didn't think that way.
He only said that he was
faithfully following through
on instructions to copy it.
But if we're going to pinpoint
individual, and here's
the details.
So that's why this is
very, very important
to look at the historical
facts and not give credit
where credit is not do.
And it's just a very,
but it should come up
with the next slide.
So here's the sources.
So anyway, these are
writers, Greek writers,
who said the same thing, that
Pythagoras, he goes to Egypt.
He studies for 22
years under a priest.
And then, he goes back
teaching geometry.
So these are the sources
that document that Pythagoras
was specifically learning
mathematics under the priest.
So here you go here.
So anyway, moving forward.
Architecture, this also
represents science.
There's another class
African contribution.
The first known architect
in the history of humanity,
the one we know by
name, is Imhotep.
Here he is.
The Greeks changed his
name to Escalapius.
So again, look at the ending.
And he's also the first known
physician in the world as well.
Almost 2,800 BCE,
Imhotep this is
an image of him
holding the scroll.
And so, the
Hippocratic Oath, there
are some people who call it the
Imhotepian Oath because Imhotep
the first known physician
that we know by name.
But I want to focus not
on the medical part,
but on his architectural
contributions.
This here is the
first stone building
in the history of the world.
This is called the
Step Pyramid today.
People, then, didn't
call it the Step Pyramid.
But somewhere around 2,700
before the common era,
you have this massive
structure, which
is over 200 feet in height.
And notice that people
today call it a Step Pyramid
because it looks like a
series of steps or benches.
So this is the first tier.
You can see the damage.
The second, third,
fourth, fifth,
so there's six different tiers.
And this is the first stone
building in the world.
This is in the
northern part of Egypt.
The oldest surviving building,
very massive structure.
And here you see it
from another image.
But take a close look at
this image in the box.
These are two people
to give you an idea
of the size of this
massive monument.
So this is the first
superstructure,
some like to call it.
super building in the
world, the first pyramid.
It definitely takes science.
I want to show you
the ones in Giza.
But inside of this
one, beautiful tile.
So if you go to the
Metropolitan Museum
in New York, which is not that
far from the Brooklyn Museum,
you can see the beautiful tile.
Or if you go to Egypt, you can
see parts of the same tile.
I can imagine this
in it's heyday.
Beautiful turquoise.
Now, this is inside.
There is many different images
inside of the Step Pyramid.
And is built for Zozer.
This is the king, the
pharaoh, the ruler
who commissioned the building of
that pyramid that you just saw.
He's got his beard, his locks.
The eyes were taken.
Now, this is part of
the original skin color
that you would see here.
He would have symbols of
authority in his hands.
Those are broken off.
But this is an
image of Zozer who
commissioned the building
of the pyramid you just saw.
And here's another pyramid.
And all these pyramids
I'm showing you now,
they pre-date, they precede
the first true pyramid.
Because I noticed that
on the history channel,
they're interviewing
Erich von Daniken.
This man wrote Chariott
of the Gods decades ago
and-- have any of you
seen ancient alien series.
Are you kidding me?
So these people make
us believe that there
are aliens that left Mars.
And they went to Africa
to build pyramids.
And then, they ascended back up.
That doesn't make any
sense because there
are numerous
pyramid in the area,
not just the ones in Giza.
So when I take people
on educational tours,
we look at the evolution
of pyramid building.
You can see how they went
from the Step Pyramid
to the Meidum Pyramid,
and then, ultimately,
to the true pyramid.
So you can see that this is an
indigenous, local innovation
and doesn't require some
interplanetary travelers
to come around and
built for Africans
what Africans supposedly
couldn't build for themselves.
This is a very steep angle.
No one really knows,
but sometimes,
in the old literature,
people call
this the Collapsed Pyramid.
It didn't collapse.
But, actually, we don't
know what happened.
This is a very steep angle here.
And here's a man to give you
an idea of the size of this.
But this would have been
built in tiers as well.
This is the second one
built after the one in Giza.
I'm sorry the one in Saqqara.
Notice this here.
It's a place called Dahshure.
And notice why people would call
this today the Bent Pyramid.
Notice the change in angle.
This would have been
a very steep angle,
but it's now in the middle.
They changed it to a
more gentler angle.
Some think, one theory is
that may be the Meidum Pyramid
so-called collapsed.
And the builders were
concerned about the same fate
of this pyramid, and
they change the angle.
That's plausible, but
we don't really know.
But nevertheless,
we do know that this
was built before
the ones in Giza
that supposedly
the aliens built.
Now, at the same
place of Dahshure,
there is also the Red Pyramid.
This is actually the first
true pyramid ever built
in the history of the world.
This one here is
about-- this is probably
about-- this is right around
2,600, 2,700, almost 2,700 BCE.
Here you have people
that are walking up
to enter into the pyramid.
So if you don't
really know where
you are, if you see an opening,
that's always the north side
because it has the north star.
But this is the Red Pyramid.
it's the first true pyramid.
And if you walk up
into the pyramid,
we have to walk up a couple
hundred feet and then, descend.
And so inside of the Red
Pyramid, as they call it,
you go down about 200 feet.
And then, there's
a series of rooms
inside of the actual
pyramid as you go down.
And you enter in from
the stairs to this area.
And there's corbelled ceilings.
So notice that
there's like-- they
call them corbelled
ceilings-- Notice
that these 11 of these part of
the corbelled ceiling about 40
feet high.
And this is graffiti
here, but this
is inside of the
pyramid where they
use large blocks of limestone.
And this is inside the monument.
This is indigenous African
innovation and architecture
inside of the Red Pyramid.
So it had nothing to do
with some people coming
from Mars to do anything.
It's unnecessary.
We can go inside.
There's a series
of three chambers.
This is the first chamber.
Here's a third chamber as
you leave the second one.
There's a lot of graffiti.
You get an idea
when people broke
into the pyramid
looking for treasure.
Somebody here made
up a false year.
Someone said 1276.
No, no one broke in here.
This is 1800s.
This person tried to
make his date earlier
than the previous
person, so I guess,
he thought his name
could last longer.
Who knows?
This one is the third corbelled
ceiling more thant 50 feet
in height.
But anyway, I'm
going to move forward
because I know time is moving.
But I wanted to show
you all of those.
All those pyramids I showed
you were all older than these.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: What makes something
the perfect true pyramid?
What's a true pyramid?
MANU AMPIM: Anything
that's a true triangle.
This is a true triangular shape.
So that's what we
call a true pyramid.
And you all know these.
You've seen these.
Some of you might have
traveled to Egypt.
If you haven't, I know
you've seen these.
So we're told with the ancient
alien series on the History
Channel that these
interplanetary travelers came
and somehow built the monument.
Doesn't make any sense.
I've shown you all
of the-- I showed you
pyramids that were built
in the process of coming
to the first true pyramid,
which we saw in Dhashure.
And then, you have the pyramids
of Khufu, Khafre, Menkaura.
These massive structures.
And by what these are
the original names.
Can you imagine a
monument equivalent
to a 48 story skyscraper?
So when people say
the great pyramids,
they mean the three
big one's here.
Or, if they say
The Great Pyramid,
they mean the one
built for Khufu.
The Greeks changed
his name to Cheops.
But this is a massive structure.
And then, the one in the middle,
built for Khafre, 471 feet.
And then, Menkaura, these
are the three Great Pyramid
builders of Giza.
This is about 2,600 BCE.
And notice they're smaller.
I didn't say small, but
simply smaller pyramids here.
These are smaller, but they're
still massive structures.
These are people here.
You say I don't really see them.
That's the point I'm making.
They're very insignificant.
These two are people.
Say I really don't see them.
That's my point.
Trust me.
There are people over
here somewhere as well.
There is a vast area.
Let's take a look here
at The Great Pyramid,
the one in the back,
Khufu's pyramid.
2.3 million stones put in place
without mortar without glue.
And you have people on camel.
2.3 million stone built
over 20 year period.
You're talking about engineering
and heavy transport techniques.
This in me a front
of one of the blocks.
The blocks weighed on
average two and 1/2 tons.
On the inside, you
have 15 ton stones.
And take a look here.
So inside, you have--
every pyramid is different.
Every pyramid is different,
different chambers,
different rooms.
And that's what you have inside
of The Great Pyramid here.
And if you take a closer
look, this is math.
This is geometry on a
sophisticated level.
This is math demonstrated
on an extraordinary level.
This is all The Great Pyramid/
There's three big ones that we
just showed you, but this is
The Great Pyramid of Khufu from
different angles.
But look at it.
It is a perfect triangle.
And here you can see you've got
a triangle here, a one here.
Here's one in the shade
and one on the backside.
If you have four
equilateral triangles
that gives you a perfect what?
Square.
This is math At a sophisticated
level that stuns the world.
And by the way, there's an
old proverb the people still
use in Egypt today, that
all the world fears time,
but time itself
fears the pyramids.
These monuments were
built for how long?
For eternity.
And you're looking at these.
Absolutely extraordinary.
And so these were not
burials by the way.
No mummies found
inside, no skeletons.
There was never any attempt for
a burial in these monuments.
These were astrological
observatories.
We know that because they-- it
helped them tell time of day.
In fact, you can
tell the time of day
based on how the sun casts
a shadow on the monument.
You can tell the time of
day, season of the year.
So let's see.
So for example,
this is the north.
This is the north side here.
This is the south side.
This would be west.
I'm sorry.
This is north, south.
This is east here, sorry.
And this is west on the left.
So given that, this orientation
that I've just mentioned,
what time of day would it be?
Morning, afternoon,
would it be evening?
AUDIENCE: It would be afternoon.
MANU AMPIM: It'd be
afternoon because the sun is
on this side.
The sun sets in the west, right?
So its sun is
setting on this side.
So it's casting a shadow
here on the east side.
So it's clearly
later in the day.
But this is what helped
them set their calendars is
by these monuments.
So there's rituals
and ceremonies,
but they were not burials.
It makes no sense for
people to say that,
but researchers don't
know all the details,
so they make up things.
By the way, when
planes fly above,
you get these kind of aerial
shots that I'm showing you.
And, definitely
based on science,
if you take a look
here, notice there's
two big pyramids
of Khufu, Khafre.
Menkaura, notice, is
a little bit offline.
Why is it offline?
Because it's consistent
with the Orion star system.
And the Orion system
is what they actually
used-- Let me go back here.
But the Orion star
system is what they use.
It's like as above so below.
So this is deliberately
set off line
because it had to do
with their astrology.
If we had an opportunity to
share with you more, I would.
But I did a presentation,
an international conference
in Atlanta, and my presentation
was on the origin and purpose
of Nile Valley pyramid
science to look
at the evolution of
pyramid building,
where the idea
came from, and what
was the deep science involved.
But this clearly has
to do with astrology
and also astronomy as well.
By the way, in the back,
you see the city of Cairo.
And, in fact, in that same
area around The Great Pyramid,
we find the oldest
surviving asphalt
in the history of the world.
This whole area was
paved with asphalt.
Talk about more than
4,600 years ago.
Here are people--
just to give you
an idea of the asphalt
that was in the area,
a whole paved area.
This is a pretty phenomenal
to say the least.
This is a image of Khufu.
Now, this is in the Brooklyn
Museum, this image here.
And this is thought to be
Khufu the one who commissioned
to building of The Great
Pyramid that you just saw.
This is a red-- this is
pink and red granite.
And the peak is red.
And now, nobody knows how
the pyramids were built.
No one knows.
It's nothing more
than speculation.
The only evidence that we
have, visual evidence of how
large stones were
moved is image here
from the tomb of Djehuti-hotep
Here you have 172 men.
Now, for every time
you see someone here,
it's actually
representing four men.
So if we had a
great image of you
can see it's a person behind
a person behind-- so these are
four for every time
you see someone.
And they're pulling ropes.
You see the different
lines of men.
They're pulling the
rope, and this rope
is securing this huge
statue of Djehuti-hotep
found in his tomb.
Notice this man is pouring
some kind of a liquid.
It's being pulled on the sled.
Why is he pouring the liquid?
To reduce friction.
And what is this man
doing here do you think?
See he's on the knees
of the huge statue.
He's clapping.
Any idea?
AUDIENCE: Working.
MANU AMPIM: He's?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MANU AMPIM: He's helping.
Yeah, he's helping in the
sense of creating a rhythm.
The work is a lot easier
when you can sing and dance.
And that's what's
happening here.
So he's creating a rhythm.
Anyway, this only
specific information we
have on how they move.
And by the way, the text
says moving a colossus.
This is the middle
pyramid of Khafre.
This was complete with
limestone, tura limestone.
This is how it was completed
in the 18th-- In the 1800s
a man named Muhammad
Ali from Turkey
had his engineers
climb up this pyramid
and strip off the limestone.
Now, it's used for bridges
and mosques around Cairo.
That's why you don't
see this completed now.
But this is math at a
very sophisticated level.
So this what we mean
by a true pyramid.
This is triangular shape.
There is something
special about this shape.
It really is.
And if you see--
this is Khafre who
commissioned the building
of the middle pyramid.
And then, the third
of these big pyramids
is Menkaura and his wife.
Notice the affection.
You always show a
hand-- there's always
affection between
husband and wife.
Her name looks difficult.
But no, not if you break it into
syllables, Kha-mer-er-nebty.
And notice this is
a beautiful image.
Notice the left foot forward.
This is classic.
And so anyway, so these are
these great pyramid builders.
This is Menkaura's
middle pyramid.
And this is math at a
very sophisticated level.
And this is the whole area here.
It wasn't built by slaves.
It had nothing to
do with slavery.
These were African astronomers
African astronomer--
astrologers, blue collar
workers, managers,
scientists who created these
monuments to last for eternity.
So these are the
three great pyramids.
And this is the place, today,
where a person can go and see
the evidence of the city of
the ancient pyramid builders
because their tombs are right
in the area near these monuments
here.
And so that's what you see in
Giza, these great monuments.
And, on the back
of the dollar bill,
you can see the African
influence there.
There is this Latin term, he
has favored our undertaking.
You have other
Latin inscription,
new order of the ages.
But which are the ones that
relate to Egypt, you might ask?
Well, the one I mentioned
to you, the eye of Heru.
Here it is.
This is not-- And
by the way, many
of the presidents of the
country were stone masons,
including the first
President, George Washington.
So it's not odd
that they would look
toward Egypt for
guidance and symbolism.
So many of them were masons,
including the first president
himself.
And then, not only the
all seeing eye of Heru,
but you have the pyramid.
They didn't get these
symbols from Greece, Rome,
or any other places.
These are pyramid--
symbols from Egypt,
so you have a lot of
the influence there.
And these are not only Masonic
symbols, but this is science.
Take a look at this
massive structure here.
This is Ramses' image.
And you don't see anybody
here, but if you look closely,
now you do.
Look at the size.
It's a 65 foot high monument.
And this temple was carved
from the mountain behind it.
Each one of these are Ramses.
He's the greatest builder
in history of Africa.
And you're standing
right underneath Ramses.
Let me show you the
science involved here.
This is why I'm
showing you this.
Here's one of the
sons of Ramses.
What a builder!
This is about 3,200 years ago.
Can you imagine?
Now, this is inside
of the temple.
Ramses is given his
crown as the king.
And then, inside of
the temple, if you
go through a series of
rooms, about 180 feet back
into the inner
sanctuary, the sun
creeps in and lights up the
statues in the back only
twice a year.
This is science at it's best.
So there's a mad rush, usually,
on February 22nd and October
22nd.
Early morning, 4:00 AM,
people go to Abu Simbel
to see one of the
great phenomenons
in the world, where
the scientists were
able to orient the temple that
the sun creeps in 180 feet
and into the back of the
temple and lights up these four
statues only twice a year.
That science because the sun,
it shines off of the Nile and it
lights up these statute's.
Early morning, people
go to Abu Simbel.
They spend the night to see
one of the great phenomenons.
But can you imagine the
knowledge of astrology
to be able to do
that and to orient
the temple in exactly that way?
This is one of the great
structures in the world.
Let me show you the
Karnak Temple here.
You see this is the sacred lake.
This is part of the-- Anybody
see any structures here
that might be familiar to us?
AUDIENCE: Obelisks.
MANU AMPIM: OK.
Obelisks.
And they're where?
AUDIENCE: On the right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, very good.
Here's one.
Here's the other one.
So notice this.
So here you have Obelisks
at the Karnak temple.
Here are two.
This one is built by
Hatshepsut, Queen Hatshepsut.
This is 97 feet,
estimated 320 tons,
made out of one single
block of granite.
Here's another one
here, a third one.
But take a look here.
This is the Tekhen, what people
now call the obelisk, 1,500
before the common era,
or 3,500 years ago.
Look similar?
This is the Washington Monument.
Notice the reflecting pool.
And this was built for
Georgia Washington,
but if you take a look at
the dates, this is in 1884.
This is thousands
of years later.
George Washington and others,
as we said a minute ago,
they were masons.
So this is why we
get this image.
So you have the original
and you have a copy.
Could there be any coincidence?
Absolutely not.
The most people don't connect
this great U.S. monument
to an African source, but
that's the reality of it.
You see it right there.
And let me just end by
showing you-- so the science,
we could say more, but,
just in case, you might say,
ah science is good, but why
do you connect it to Africa.
OK, well, let's
address that issue here
whenever this comes up.
This is the greatest statue
on Earth, the most well-known,
the most famous statue
in history of the world.
You know it as the Great Sphinx.
The original name
is Heru-em-akhet,
or the god Heru in the horizon.
Notice that it's in Giza.
So this is the Great
Pyramid of Khufu.
This is the one in the middle.
If you go down the hill,
here's this monument here.
Here you can see it.
It's down the hill.
This is a man.
Give you an idea.
This is a 66 foot high monument.
As you can see, it
has a head of a person
and the body of a
lion 240 feet long.
This is the greatest and most
well-known statue on earth.
But I'm showing you
this because most times
you see the front view,
where, obviously, there's
deliberate nose damage.
Some people think Napoleon
trained his canons
to blow it off.
I think not.
That would have been a
heck of a cannon shot.
I think, more likely, they
sawed it off, but not Napoleon.
The nose was missing long before
Napoleon in around 1799, long
before that.
But what we don't often
see is the profile view.
You don't often see the
Africoid profile view.
Because even with
the nose missing,
notice the cheek bones
notice-- uh oh, there they go.
Notice the juicy kissing lips.
These lips are meant for
smooching and affection.
And this is clearly
an Africaoid image,
but you don't normally
see the profile view.
But here it is.
That's it.
And so I have many
other images of this,
but that one you can see.
So the most well-known statue
in the world, you see it.
It's Africoid.
And there's a reason
why people don't often
get a chance to see the
profile view because how do you
explain this.
All right.
Let me show you other images.
That's not enough for you.
You all are a tough audience.
So let's show you
some other images.
The tomb of Kagemni.
Most people don't go there,
but I take every group
to Kagemni's tomb.
And this is a tomb that
around the time of Ptah Hotep.
If you have noticed, the color
is off here on the projector.
But this is more
reddish than brown here.
But you have different
color images.
When they wanted to juxtapose
one person to another.
But notice they didn't use
any really light colors.
Now on the tomb of
Ramses III, I want--
this is the King's
Valley Tomb number 11.
That's what KV stands for.
And this is about 1200
BCE, or 3,200 years ago.
What do you notice here?
Notice you see a
person a and what else?
Person c.
Noticed this.
This is interesting
because they're
dressed-- They're jet black
and dressed identical.
This is actually in
the tomb of Ramses III.
This is how the artist
depicted themselves.
This says here ramesh,
or it just means people.
It just means the
people of Egypt.
This here says Nahesi.
Nahesi just means
those to the south.
So it's interesting
that the people
in Egypt, the artist in
this case, in a royal tomb--
this is not some side artist.
This is a royally
trained artists,
depicted the people in Egypt
jet black and identical
to other Africans
from the South.
So KV 11, if you get a chance to
go, you want to check that out.
You can see.
But not only that, but
there's other things too.
Someone said, well,
those images don't exist.
Are you kidding me?
This is inside of
the tomb itself.
And you still have the
same black skin images.
So KV 11.
Now, what do you think this is?
I want to end by just
showing you a couple slides
and I'm done.
I just want to show
you the identity.
What do you think this is?
Comb.
What kind of comb?
It has a pick.
Afro pick.
And our hair-- sometimes
the teeth are broken.
You know in the old days?
You know when people--
so just if you
look at one line of evidence,
you can indicate the identity.
Sometimes, people say, yes,
I agree it's a high culture,
but I don't think it has
anything to do with Africans.
Well, let's address that issue.
If you just look
at combs and hair,
we can address that as we close.
Here is sister [? Hanoop ?].
What is she doing?
She's braiding hair.
This is the hieroglyphic image
for just that, braiding hair.
This is an African hairstyle.
People often say, I
love your French braids.
Well, it actually doesn't have
anything to do with the French.
This is African hairstyle.
It goes back many thousands
of years as you see here.
Take a look at this beautiful
image of a princess.
Notice she has her
jewelry, a bouquet,
the almond-shaped
eyes, and, yes, you
have the beautiful
braided hair, and a linen
outfit because people wear
linen a lot when it's very hot.
Not only that, take a
look at Queen Thepu.
Notice the beautiful
skin tone, the jewelry,
almond-shaped eyes.
And they wore wigs sometimes.
This is more likely her hair,
but when they did wear wigs,
it is always human hair.
And notice how
beautiful it is here.
Not only that, but you
can look at other images.
Here, this one is a wig here.
But it's Ahmose-Nefertari,
She is always
depicted in this manner.
Notice her symbols of authority.
This is her name, so
a high-level queen.
But the wigs are
always human hair.
But not only that,
but take a look
at how kings are represented.
This is Amenemhet III.
And so running the nation, he
was a king of the 12th dynasty.
He has on locks
here, very powerful.
And so tell rasta that we
appreciate the culture,
but the rasta didn't
originate the dreads.
You them right here.
This is in the Cairo museum.
Amenemhet IIII, a
very powerful ruler
who ruled doing a very
important time period.
This is the image
of the first known
dentist in the
history of humanity.
The first known dentist
by name, Hesy-Re.
And notice he had--
this is not a wig.
This is his hair.
This is fro.
And Hesy-Re, when you go
into the Cairo Museum,
he is off to the side.
Most of the guys walk
right past Hesy-Re.
And unless the
person is curious,
they have to actually
go behind a little area
to look at the
Hesy-Re paintings.
There are 6 of these that
have been found from his tomb.
Third dynasty, this
is about 2,800 BCE.
He's the first known
dentist that we
know of by name in the
history of the world.
Notice the helical
structure of the hair.
This is clearly
in Africoid image.
There's a couple
more images here.
You have wigs in the Cairo
Museum worn by priests.
Notice these Afro wigs.
Notice even the dolls they
played with, even the beads
representing what?
Braided hair.
This one line of evidence
here, just hair, combs.
And this is a man.
Here's King Tut.
These are statue in his tomb.
This is original golden
mask of Tutankhamen.
[INAUDIBLE] gold found
on his mummy about 3,300
in-- Did anybody go to the King
Tut exhibit at the de Young?
Yes.
And so you went to the--
so this is Tutankhamen.
This is his mother Queen Tiye.
Now, if the new DNA
tests are correct,
and we don't know that they are.
But if they are, that,
instead of his mother,
this would be his grandmother.
Either way it's still all in
the family, Africoid family.
I'm just showing you
someone that everybody
is familiar with.
If this is not his
father, Amenhotep III,
it would be his grandfather,
still all in a family.
And then, this is Tutankhamen,
original images of him.
And then, finally, this is
what was in the exhibit.
You might recall this
image of Tutankhamen.
This is like a mannequin
of Tutankhamen.
And finally, this is just a
brief, very brief information
that I wanted to share with
you about African contribution
in math and science.
And thank you very much.
I'm Professor Manu Ampim.
Thank you very much.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank
you all for coming.
Did anybody have any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
have a question.
You said a couple
time, yeah this
is the first book or the
first stone building.
When you say it,
you mean like this
is the first one
that you know of?
Or, you actually
have people who are
saying oh this is
literally the first time
anybody's seen this here.
We have the record of that
this was created, [INAUDIBLE].
MANU AMPIM: The
first we know of.
Yes, the first we know of.
And that's how I typically
try to explain it.
But yeah, good ques--
first we know of.
It's like because--
Like, for example,
when we see Imhotep as
the first known architect,
but he just pops up and
there's a great building.
So we have to assume there has
to be some period before that.
AUDIENCE: We just don't know.
MANU AMPIM: Yeah, we
just don't know exactly.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's just the
color in the paintings
really didn't
necessarily represent
the color [INAUDIBLE].
MANU AMPIM: OK.
With this--
AUDIENCE: Like the
red and the black.
MANU AMPIM: But this,
as you see, is pixelated
and the colors are all off.
But outside of that,
AUDIENCE: I mean that the
people that are in the-- yeah.
MANU AMPIM: Yeah, I know.
And I just wanted to say
that so-- the colors are
off of what you're seeing here.
I don't know what's going on.
But anyway, people like to
say that this is stylized.
In other words, it's
stylized or idealized.
It's not really how
the people looked.
And so people like
to-- actually,
if you take a look at--
maybe it's my eyes.
That one looks closer
to the original here.
It's not just me, is it?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: That one's
probably redder.
MANU AMPIM: Yeah, this
is more authentic.
I should have been--
should have turned
a-- I should have
walked to the back.
So that's more accurate.
But that argument
that oh the people
were depicted that way,
that it's idealized.
No, because of if you see
one image of Tutankhamen,
you can tell.
If we had a collage
of different images,
you would always be
able to pick him out.
Because these people try
to say they idealized him.
People didn't look like that.
No.
You can see, specifically,
in the paintings
and the sculpture.
It's exactly how they look.
Mummies have been found.
They've been depicted
by other groups as well.
It is very consistent.
People try to get around
that because they would
like the public to think
that this had nothing
to do with Africa, and
these dark skinned images
are really not the reality.
So now what people tried
to do is use forensic art
to come up with some
brand new images
of how the people looked.
And it's not necessary to
do that because we have
from his tomb, for example,
there's more than 5,000 items.
And most of them have
images of Tutankhamen.
And they're very,
very consistent
not only from his tomb, but from
other images of him as well.
So the idea-- this argument
that this is idealized
and they just happen to
look African is really not.
AUDIENCE: That wasn't
really where I was going.
MANU AMPIM: OK.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Where do
you feel [INAUDIBLE]?
I'm trying to think
of the one shown where
was sort of like some of them
were black, and some of them
were red, and some
of them were yellow.
In those pictures, and you
were saying that [INAUDIBLE].
And so I was just-- I have heard
that that represents patience.
It doesn't necessarily
represent the color
that the people that wrote
them colored them to be.
[INAUDIBLE].
You know what I'm
talking about now?
MANU AMPIM: Yeah, let's see.
You might be-- let
me show you two.
I think you might be familiar
with the Table of Nations.
This is the one on Kush.
You're not talking
about that one, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
a pretty good one.
MANU AMPIM: OK.
If we use this one, this is
exactly how the people look.
Exactly.
In fact, if anybody goes to
Sudan today, or the heartland
of Kush, people look
exactly like that.
There is various
shades of brown.
There is like the black color.
It's various shades of black.
There's chocolate.
There's a gray black blue, a
blue black, super black, wild
black, amazing
black, perfect black.
I mean in Sudan.
AUDIENCE: The color is
also better back there.
MANU AMPIM: This is much better.
Yeah, that's much, much there.
But that's exactly how-- so
when I first went to Sudan,
I really didn't
know what to expect.
So it makes sense
to me-- and besides,
the people who named the
place the Lot El Sudan, that's
an Arab phrase meaning
land of the blacks.
That's literally what it means.
Even the term Ethiopia,
is a Greek term which
means burnt face, blackface.
or kissed by the sun.
So those images that you
actually see are very accurate.
The people in Sudan
and Nubians-- Nubians
are in southern Egypt
and northern Sudan.
You can see those
variations even today.
And not only that,
but, the other one
that you mentioned,
they're very specific.
They're very specifically.
The artists were
very, very detailed
in how they portrayed
things, not only people,
but they are so specific you
can see the species of plants,
the species of fish,
because they were very, very
detailed in how they present it.
So here, when you
see-- there's better,
but how the people dress,
their attire, the details,
their beards, all these
things are very accurate.
And this is how
we're able to tell
not only from the inscriptions,
but how they're depicted.
So they really didn't-- They
were not loose with how they
portrayed people.
But some have said these
are just generalized.
They are not generalized.
They are very specific.
And that's why a person
goes to a museum,
they can see that,
in many cases,
you go to different museums,
there's no name of the person.
And the location, it will
say provenance unknown.
In other words,
there are assuming
that this statue represents
that person because
of the stylistic--
specific stylistic details.
And because of that, they
say it must be this person.
You see that many times, assumed
to be King such and such.
And they say provenance unknown
because they don't know.
They bought it from somebody.
And how could they assume who
it is if they all look alike.
No, it's very specific.
And you can see the variations
of skin tone, dress.
So that's a whole
other argument,
but it's actually a
great question though.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: You said no one knows
how the pyramids were erected.
Then, you also said that it
wasn't constructed by slaves.
Is there evidence
some way or the other?
MANU AMPIM: Oh, yeah.
There's clear evidence that it
was not constructed by slaves.
And let me show you here.
Good question.
Let me show this place here.
I took out a lot of
slides, but this place here
Nazlet El-Semman And
this location here,
as of 1992, the Giza mapping
project led by Mark Lehner,
we now know the tombs have been
found of the actual pyramid
builders.
We know their titles,
what days they worked,
what days they had off.
So they would work 7 days
and then have 3 days off.
That was a week.
So a week was a 10 day period.
So there were 3 10 day weeks.
They worked 7 days, 3 days
off, work 7 days, 3 days off,
work 7 days off.
We know they were paid with
grains of wheat, grains
of barley, and with linen cloth.
So the records were very clear
that these were paid laborers,
that no one was involved
in forced labor.
So the place of Nazlet
El-Semman since '91-- actually,
since '92, now, the slavery
argument it has no weight.
Before that, people argued
it without evidence.
Now, the argument can't
be advanced anymore
because of the evidence
at Nazlet El-Semman
and knowing when people were
paying and how they were paid.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So there's
evidence for all
the different positions?
MANU AMPIM: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I thought
that's why they depicted
the different or other
people pulling the sled.
And there's the
keeper or something.
But I thought that all
the people were paid.
MANU AMPIM: Yeah, absolutely.
So you have evidence of--
because there's tombs.
Because when
somebody has a tomb,
the tomb is the person--
like a tombstone today,
it would have the person's
name, when they were born,
when they passed away.
But there is a big tomb where
it indicates all their life
achievements, but
also their titles,
the titles of family members.
So we know the titles,
what they claim
to accomplish in their life.
And you see that at
that location there,
there's-- what's been found
is the bakery, the brewery,
the tombs, their titles.
So they're all laid out.
And not only their
titles, but also
how the-- they call it
a [? zha ?] or people
translate it as a gang,
not a gang of thugs,
but a gang of workers.
How they were organized
to do the work.
So, usually, they would
work in 3 month shifts.
And then, they would go
back into their communities.
So that it was a
public works project
built by Africans stonemasons.
And in fact, there was communal,
cooperative, and collective
public works projects.
It had nothing do with slavery.
But those tombs, and the
titles, and how and when people
were paid, that sealed
the case of '92.
AUDIENCE: --comment.
Wasn't there a documentary
made when they were excavated?
MANU AMPIM: Yes, it was.
And if you look up
Mark Lehner, they had--
So Mark Lehner's
got these theories
of how the pyramids were built.
And so this is when the
Discovery Channel showed it.
They had a bunch of men
like pulling these stones.
They wanted to see how to
build a miniature pyramid.
So the camera showed
the men, heave ho heave.
And so they're
pulling the stones.
So they showed the
men and the ropes.
And then, when I went to
Egypt a few months later,
I'll learned that
what they didn't show
was the tractor that was
really pulling in the stone.
So this is a joke,
but nevertheless, that
was because they did find the
evidence of the actual pyramid
builders.
Now, as I said,
that argument really
doesn't have any weight anymore.
But if you look up
Mark Lehner, you
can actually see
some of their evidece
because he's the one
that's really over the site
now, Mark Lehner.
But that really just
helped slay the argument.
AUDIENCE: A follow up here.
So there still
were slaves, right?
So was there [INAUDIBLE]
edition that--
who actually got
a part at the job,
and then, slaves
had other roles?
MANU AMPIM: Slaves.
The slave idea comes
from two sources,
from the biblical idea
and then some of the later
Greek writers, who had no
idea how they were built,
so they made up
a lot of stories.
So many people think that
there were slaves in the Bible
that built pyramids.
The problem is the very
first Hebrew was Abraham.
Abraham was dated to
about 1600 or 1650 BCE.
The problem is that that's 1,000
years after these were built.
So how could Abraham
leap through history,
1,000 years before him,
and build pyramids?
So there's no evidence
of any slaves whatsoever.
What you do see
though is that when
Egypt-- when other nations
tried to invade Egypt,
you do see captors.
You see prisoners of
war, but you never
see them being employed
into any kind of labor.
So you see that.
You see bound captives.
And then, the Greeks came around
and made up a lot of stories.
Herodotus is a very good
source for Greek myth
like, for example, Herodotus
is saying that-- Herodotus
is a good source
because he reports what
he saw at the time, at 500 BCE,
and he reports what he heard.
And so Herodotus relays myths.
And he said, look, I'm just
going to say what the Greeks
say .
So according to the
Greek mythology,
Khufu-- those smaller pyramids
were built because Khufu's
daughter, supposedly, was
involved with prostitution.
And for every man
that she slept with,
she asked that
they bring a stone.
Incredible.
And that this is how
the monument was built.
First of all, there is
no evidence of this.
This is silly.
This is the king's daughter.
He has tons of
wealth, so why would
she need to engage in that.
But it almost seems
like Herodotus
is half embarrassed
by reporting this.
But this is the Greek--
the Greek's made up
stories for things
they didn't understand.
But those are the two sources.
And, of course, the
Ten Commandments
and all these other things
have come out over the years.
This is what has
presented to the public
that there's slavery.
But there is no
slavery whatsoever.
I didn't say that
they were perfect.
I said there's no slavery.
Because all we do see
is we see captives
that are bound in warfare.
But there's nobody employed.
There's is no text.
There's no images of it.
But the idea of slaves
building the pyramid,
that's been in the
public mind for awhile.
And then, when the evidence
was found at Nazlet El-Semman
and you had people writing about
slavery, then, they say, uh-oh.
The evidence is there.
We'd better back up.
So they backed away
from those claims.
But a lot of the
specialists were
the ones promoting
the slavery idea.
So that's where we are.
And if we had time,
I would really
show you the evidence from here.
I didn't include these slides
because it's interesting
when you actually see the
evidence of the actual workers,
and the city that they worked
in, and how they were paid.
You can see it.
It shows you.
Any other-- Well, thank
you for your time folks.
I really appreciative it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
I can give you guys--